this male bonobo chimpanzee may look
like a dominant male but he's really
just a big mama's boy that's because in
bonobo society the Mamas hold lots of
power it's shared between males and
females
this alpha female is one of the group's
leaders don't believe it
watch how she snaps this sapling then
struts her stuff in a way that would
make any dominant male chimpanzee prowl
the message is clear this babe is boss
these embossing adult females form
strong bonds with their offspring
especially the males all babies are
intimately cared for through the first
five years but eventually young female
bonobos must leave the truth and find
another troop to accept them the sons
stay behind and the ones with the most
powerful mothers become the most
privileged males bonobo mother's almost
never discipline their young even when
they steal food right out of Mom's mouth